hey hey what's going on we're going to a
break right now on love lines we're in
the westwood 1 studios in the heart of
Los Angeles so I was just hanging out
with david lawrence AKA Eric Doyle not
one shoko heroes you might have heard of
it and we're here in the studio watching
the live recording of love line now we
weren't actually on the show we were
just visiting so what do we do it we
just like sit and enjoy and admire the
fact that there's five pieces of glass
between us and dr. drill instructor yes
that is exactly what you do and you wait
and wait and wait and wait you wait
until the commercial break and you pop
in and say hey hi hey hi okay all right
so I'm here with dr. Drew and I'm gonna
ask him the important question it is a
question what's your favorite treats
treats treats treats like a smart snack
treats snack treats snack treats snack
treats snack yeah a treat like a snack
pizza people about we just ordered that
but it's pizza you ordered it online
right yes that's the nasty Claire left
I'm not running in and then what that's
what I think it sounds like when you
pizza don't judge I don't be sayin all
their coupons to fun Pizza Pizza watch
me toughest delicious delicious it's dry
can say the truth Oh tracker hey my god
what's your favorite treat my favorite
treats treat treat um I enjoy didn't
Plenty's before I let him continue
please note that he said good & Plenty's
good in frooties milky ways and good a
little ribbon ice cream wait a min the
good & Plenty's like the purple and
white things yes oh really really never
met anyone who likes those that is
amazing I love him I like chewy candy I
like um this out who's been over don't
you haha this is the peanut gallery over
here let's talk about it's a good thing
so please continue on striker more about
those delicious treats
I really enjoy going into candy shops
where they have a shovel everyone's hand
is touching scooping it in like brown
liquor sits bald and like the coffee and
real aggression haha I still can't get
over the good & Plenty's and last but
not least what's David's favorite treat
cuz everybody knows bagels and coffee
I'm right there with them on the coffee
in particular banana nut with plain
cream cheese and some sort of vanilla
ish coffee yeah and that's my trip to
loveline peace out wait still cannot get
over why do I have to put adjust in
there I just still cannot I just still
cannot get over the good & Plenty's our
way a scriptwriter now I'm gonna take it
as a little fake thank you can all get
in a good place I'm gonna kill this curl
[Music]